foreign
Bank of America accused of opening fake
accounts and charging illegal fees
Federal Regulators said Tuesday they
found that Bank of America harmed
customers by double dipping on fees
withholding credit card rewards and
opening fake accounts all of which are
violations of various Consumer Financial
Protection laws yeah because it's
freaking fraud and as a result the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
ordered Bank of America to pay more than
100 million dollars to customers and 90
million dollars in penalties and the
office of the Comptroller of the
currency also ordered Bank of America to
pay 60 million dollars in fines so let
me get this straight 100 million went to
the customers and 150 million went to
the government
last decade that in involved opening
millions of bank accounts without
customer authorization the cfpb said
that Bank of America harmed hundreds of
thousands of consumers over a period of
several years and across multiple
product lines and services among them
they found that the bank which normally
charged customers 35 dollars for a
transaction that was declined due to
insufficient funds allowed those fees to
be repeatedly charged for the same
transaction resulting in customers being
charged tens of millions of dollars in
fees on resubmitted transactions they
also said the bank would make special
offers of cash and points when signing
up for a new credit card but that it
illegally withheld those promised
bonuses to tens of thousands of
customers never even got your credit
card points and from at least 2012 the
agency said in order to reach now
defunct sales based incentive goals and
boost their evaluations Bank employees
illegally applied for and enrolled
consumers in credit card accounts with
out consumers knowledge and
authorization involved using or
obtaining Consumers Credit reports
without their consent and it resulted in
customers being charged unjustified fees
making hits to their credit reports and
having to make efforts to correct the
errors the bank made
someone needs to go to jail
hello
someone needs to go to jail for that
so yeah when Wells Fargo did the same
thing they um it was too it was like it
was crazy it was like I had to look it
up because I couldn't believe they laid
off like 24
000 people
yeah I remember that and because I
couldn't believe that but they had like
something like 300 000 people on the
payroll it's hard to get my head around
how big these stinking cabals are
they're bigger than most countries
and they apparently think they make
their own laws
yeah
somebody like an actual actual people
are opening these accounts absolutely
and actual people are charging these
fees employees yeah yeah yeah in order
to make their own bonuses yeah on sales
incentive goals right I just want people
to understand this is not like a digital
error or it was uh you know there was no
there was no oops involved yeah these
are people
doing evil things they're called Crooks
Crooks they're called Banks
and is no one going going to jail for
this I don't understand if you rob a
bank you go to jail but if you rob the
people you don't it's like if you're a
bank you're allowed to Rob yeah banks
are allowed to rob the people but people
can't Rob the banks this is how it works
what's going on it just seems unfair oh
man it is unfair Banks can rob the
people but the people can't Rob the
banks explain this to a five-year-old
please okay honey it's called Bank of
America they're bigger than life
okay so Bank of America Wells Fargo
among others the birds of a feather
flock together why would you continue to
do business with a company aside from
all this Malarkey this complete
crookridge going on here why would you
do business with Bank of America to
start with I don't know honestly they
treat you like crap
they don't even know you're there no you
should be doing business with your local
credit union or your small town bank or
at least at the most a regional local
bank
all of Ramsey Solutions all of Dave and
Sharon Ramsey are at banks located in
this area yeah and uh and we don't and
we actually have human beings that we
can call if there is some kind of a
problem
you know and so yeah don't do why would
you do business
with my because I'll tell you why some
of you are there because you opened your
account there and you're too stinking
lazy to move it that's what I'm saying
is right around the corner I can just
you don't want to drive
you got on direct deposit you got all
this stuff on auto draft and you don't
want to shut it all down and you don't
want to go the 18 you know maybe maybe
50 or 100 people you got to contact re
yes I think you don't want to go to all
that trouble and so you're still doing
business with Bank of America and Wells
Fargo why that's the only possible
reason I can come up with yeah
and I'm preaching to a
person who used to be a member of the
choir myself
don't overdraw
if we can get our overdrafts that might
have saved us let me just tell you a
little matter with these guys apparently
if you just do business with them
they'll pull your credit report and open
an account in your name no that's true
that's the that's the extra shady
is that this is like shade Beyond shade
it's shade Beyond shade uh I'm scared
yeah I can't believe I just can't
believe that people can do this people
can't Rob the banks but the banks can
rob the people
this is how it works because no one's
going to jail here no one's going to
and the government got more money than
the customers
I think there's just there's like
there's a lot of crooks involved here
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
got 90 million the office of the
Comptroller got 60 million wow one plus
one is 150 million by the way 90 and 60.
and 100 million went back to the
customers
shoe
well I get that you find them and I
guess you probably couldn't figure out
all the money to give to which customers
because it's real complicated when
you're dealing with a crook of this size
um and a monster with this many heads
it's hard to cut them off because
another head growth exactly it's I
wonder what 150 I wonder if 250 million
that's a quarter of a billion did
anything to their stock price with this
announcement
I bet it didn't you don't think so not
much because I mean the profit that they
got
was much greater than the cost they made
a lot more than 250 million in all this
crook region that's true man this is
insane they actually got an Roi on
crookridge wow yeah it's I'll bet you
I'm not positive but no that makes what
you're saying makes 35 and you know they
just they insufficient and insufficient
and insufficient and insufficient and
people don't pay any attention well
that's what I'm saying people most
people don't even know probably that
this was taking place whether it's
because they're not looking at their
bank account statements or they're not
looking at their credit report to see
fraudulent accounts showing up or
something this is just if you're going
to do business with Crooks you've got to
monitor no something that's the problem
with doing business with Crooks just
don't do business with them don't do
business with Wells Fargo I mean don't
do business with these Mega Banks Fifth
Third there's another one
it's the fifth time I've robbed you and
the third time that you've paid for it
oh boy the banks can rob the people but
the people can't Rob the banks this is
how it works that's the moral of the
terrorists that's what comes out of this
that's what I'm getting from it so they
opened fake accounts tens of millions of
dollars in fees on resubmitted uh
transactions that's just on the nsf's
they open Fake accounts and you know how
as big a problem as we have with
identity theft now now you have to worry
about your Banker stealing your identity
earlier in the show they said we
voluntarily reduced overdraft fees and
eliminated all non-sufficient funds fees
in the first half of 2022 like that's
like well thank you very much yeah I'm
like what are you saying you don't
didn't screw as many people
we screwed fewer people this year than
in other years
[Laughter]
a release on it and everyone's smiled
right
oh gosh this is terrible yeah
it's terrible so what's the lesson we've
learned what's the big takeaway Dave
don't do business with mega Banks period
period because you know how many you
know how many times they overdrafted me
none none I don't do business with them
you know how many accounts they opened
in my name none they don't have my
information because I don't do business
with Bank of America I don't do business
with Wells Fargo I don't walk up into
the snake pit and wonder why I got bit
true that